let me try this another way ladies and
gentlemen if you could please take your
seats we will begin the closing ceremony
right now
a good speech should be like a comet
dazzling and gone in the blink of an eye
so I'm gonna make this short and sweet I
first like to thank you all for joining
us here at the closing ceremony for the
2015 Singh field cup of course I'd like
to thank the world chess Hall of Fame
for hosting us if you haven't had a
chance to explore the exhibits on the
first and second floor I would
definitely recommend seeing those
they're beautiful and and full of rich
chess history and I think you'll
appreciate and enjoy them this is the
first year for the grand chest tour and
the Sinquefield Cup is the second
tournament in that leg the grand chest
tour was developed as a partnership
between the London chess classic Norway
chess and the scene field cup in order
to show what chess could and should be
these three events represent the gold
standard in in the world of professional
level competition coverage media
attention and details for the players
simple things like lighting and
temperature right the grand chests or as
I mentioned being this partnership I'm
lucky to be joined today by JJ who
actually has a longer name than that but
I can't pronounce it so we call him JJ
JJ is our partner from Norway chess
which was a very successful event that
occurred earlier in the year in June and
unfortunately Malcolm Payne is unable to
join us he was here on the front end and
Malcolm is the organizer for in London
chess and Michael quartic have ski and
garry kasparov with the Kasparov chess
foundation really introduced the three
of us and started the ball rolling down
this path of the grand chest tour going
to some some thanks of course and the
coverage from the seen field Cup this
year has to have been the best of any
year I've ever seen the engaging
commentary for the live audience by
Robert has Ian Rogers Ben Feingold the
social media presence and play-by-play
action by Alejandro Ramirez our
in-studio audience with Jennifer shadi
Maurice Ashley and yasser sarah juan and
of course the behind the scenes of
people you don't realize how many folks
it takes to put on an event like this
spectrum studios fat chimp
fleischman-hillard our our PR and
marketing firm
in all of the the vendors staff
employees at the Chess Club in the world
chess Hall of Fame that made it a big
success a big round of applause to all
of you thank you
of course none of this would mean
anything if the media didn't care about
it I'd like to thank that the chess
media the local st. Louis media and the
international media that are present
here are we watching this online as well
at Grantchester calm if I can plug that
the the sink filled cup wouldn't be
possible without the two individuals
responsible for its namesake Rex and
Jeanne Singh field saw the vision of
what chess could be of what the future
of chess looks like and they were
willing to commit to making st. Louis a
huge part of that so we couldn't have
done this without you Rex and Judy thank
you both very much and it's my pleasure
now to hand the microphone over to
Jeanne for a few remarks
Jean thank you Tony welcome to st. Louis
before I introduce Rex I want to
introduce the teams for tomorrow
ultimate moves can Randy come up over
here and on our left team Randy Ruslan
couple of Alexander Krishna's Wesley so
magnus carlsen Jerry all extra person
garry kasparov will come tomorrow and
recs are here Levon Aronian
now I did want to talk to this group
about the rules for trash talk I was
carefully told there weren't any no
rules okay
my children were small I had a set of
rules
I was not dumb if they were going to
insult me they had to use three syllable
words so I want you to know that I am an
imbecile
so this will be a lot of fun so I hope
that Rex has been studying very hard and
Randy here has been sweaty
you'll be sweating all day tomorrow so
let the games begin and here is my
loving husband Rex
Thank You Jeanne I don't have any three
syllable words but I do have a three
word sentence you're going down so I
want to echo the thanks to everybody of
course to Jennifer Yaser and Maurice I
sometimes believe that if we didn't have
a chess tournament and they commented
everybody in the world would still be
watching and Randy and all of his crew
and to Tony and the chess staff and fat
chimp you know I saw you guys you get
here early everyday you stay late you're
our operations you in fact are our
oxygen and none of this would have been
pulled off as beautifully as it was
without your expertise and dedication so
thank you very much
now we're lucky that st. Louis has a lot
of friends of chess but the very best
friend we have who's been here for
almost every event is the Honorable
mayor of st. Louis Francis Slay well
thank you Rex and good evening everyone
this I tell you what this does not get
old chefs and st. Louis does not get old
and I am thrilled as mayor of the city
to be standing here this evening albeit
with my back to all of you here - first
of all welcome all the competitors who
are with us I know some of you have been
here in the past others it's their first
time in st. Louis but thank you for
treating st. Louis in the world of
course - just the best chess in the
world right here in the city of st.
Louis we are thrilled to be the chess
capital of the United States and this
event and the world that the US
Championships that are here as well and
a lot of other things that are going on
here in st. Louis relative to chess
really helps solidify our position in
that regard and what that means for our
city is immeasurable in terms of the
international exposure that we get in in
in terms of the prestige that it brings
to our city particularly with talented
individuals like all of you here in our
city so I want to thank you for being
part of this thank you for helping us
you know get the international attention
on st. Louis but also thank you for
being part of the one of the greatest if
not the greatest chess tournament
anywhere in the world so we're pleased
to have you here I want to congratulate
Levon Aronian in particular for your
success here in st. Louis we
we like to think we had something to do
with your success here we think it's the
st. Louis hospitality and and the great
support that we provide to the game into
this tournament as well so thank you
congratulations to all of you and
congratulations especially to LaVon and
I want to thank the the sing fields as
well Wrexham and Jeanie for you know
their great support for for chess for
making chess something that's been just
part of our fabric now and in the past
several years and really helping st.
Louis be recognized internationally as a
result but also for what you do to
spread the importance of chess and the
popularity of chess not just here in st.
Louis but all over the United States of
America we are very proud to have you
two here and the Chess Club as well
thank you so much on behalf the people
of st. Louis and I wish all the best in
your competition tomorrow you know it's
funny one of the questions I get asked a
lot by the non chess media just general
media is why is this so important what
what's what's so great about this and I
said it's like having the Super Bowl
every night for two weeks but in between
you also get to go out to dinner with
all the players and hang out with them
and really get to know them and their
personalities I can tell you that there
are no better representatives of chess
than our superstars that we have up here
so now we enter the phase of the closing
ceremony where we discuss some of the
logistics we'll kick off a press
conference now everyone's welcome to ask
questions of the players and if you have
any questions with regards to the grand
chest tour itself
JJ and I will be happy to field those I
can tell you that in 2016 the grand
chester has secured dates for all three
of our events Norway London st. Louis
Norway will be April 16th through the
29th st. Louis st. Louis will be August
19th through September 2nd and London is
November 3rd through December 13th so
mark your calendars for
the next best chess events in the
history of the game November 30th
through December 13th sorry
Grandmaster Maurice Ashley who so
energetically and Abele handled all of
the commentary questions that could come
his way is now going to emcee the press
conference for us and we'll be happy to
call on you if you have any questions
Maurice
thank you before I start mayor slays
assistant JP when we were introduced he
asked me if I was a good chess player
and and so I was like yeah well you know
I'm probably not one of the top 10
players in the room and then I thought
about and I thought you know what the
paraphrase LeBron James I'm probably not
11 not 12 not 30 not 14 you throw a rock
and you can hit a gangster in this room
they're everywhere and it's incredible
to see the great chess that has emerged
here in st. Louis so Rex I want to thank
you
but that Genie although all the
contributions you've done but these are
the original chess gangsters right here
top 10 players I'm gonna throw out the
first question and then anyone else who
has a question may ask I want to ask
starting with Wesley so Wesley this was
your first time on a grand chest tour I
know it wasn't the greatest tournament
for you what's your thoughts and the
experience that you had at this
tournament
there well my thoughts have been we're
all very positive I am very glad to be
here thank you all the people who made
it happen
thank you your slave for attending all
the prestigious chess events in st.
Louis every year without fail if I
remember correctly were also here in
April for the US Championships and or
thank you to Rex and Jeanne for making
this author man happen for a third time
in a row well I'm very glad to be here
so well I'm not much to say about my
tournament but it's my first time and
hopefully gets better and better every
year first I'm very happy and proud to
be with with some of the top players
here and of course I'm sitting right now
beside the current world champion so
it's a big honor mmm not sure what else
you want me to say more there was on
your minds thank you does anyone have a
question for I'll then continue with
Vishwanath on on on fishy you basically
this year first time in st. Louis first
time in the United States in a while
what was your experience playing in this
event although you didn't perform to
your lofty standards my experience was
wonderful I mean the hospitality of
everyone especially Rex and Jeanne but
also everyone involved in the
organization of the event is perfect I
felt very comfortable sometimes the
chest doesn't click but that doesn't
really kalam experience and I had a
great time here so especially this
combination you know the Hall of Fame
the diner the club
it makes for a very special atmosphere
because you can also bring friends along
and things like that it's a perfect
plate a place to play chess and enjoyed
myself very much and we expect to see
you back next year I hope so fantastic
if I may go to
I go to Fabiano Caruana last year's
winner papi u-17 the know started
something to know last year your
expectations must have been high for
this year he didn't work out what are
your thoughts after this one of men is
now over uh yeah I mean it all went
wrong from the start for me but and I
still had a good time I think it was
just a great atmosphere and yeah I think
that the exciting chess is just starting
and last night was great and tonight I
think will be even better I think
there's an inside joke for those of you
who don't know apparently his manager
Lawrence Trent who's probably hiding his
head right now was playing some blitz
against Magnus Carlsen a rook up and
allowed Magnus to win four games this is
what chess players do after the
tournament is over stay up till 5:30 in
the morning playing blitz and apparently
there's some more stuff happening
tonight which is supposed to involve me
there's a hustle involved here we'll
we'll see how that works out I'd like to
move on to Veselin Topalov whistling you
on the grand chest or a inaugural event
inaugural event in Norway you started
off well here but it didn't all come
together what are your thoughts now that
the tournament is over
I simply collapsed physically now you're
only on only now I realized in two years
I didn't make even watch to the swimming
pool
so swimming for the chase took at least
once to the gym your thoughts about the
hospitality Thank You Alexander Greece
Chuck
your first time here is it the first
time you played in the United States no
it's not the first time I play
you knew the United States but it's the
first time in San Luis and what are your
thoughts now that the tournament is over
about the experience first of all I
really like the city I mean at least
this area we are living it and play the
mayor right here you're saying that in
front so it was very nice I mean I mean
the very first thing is that I needed
some electric adapter because you have
different plugs in u.s. than in Europe
and ok so they told me to go to Euclid
Street and then I went to this Euclid
Street and I realized there were like 20
amazing cook in the restaurant so
immediately I fall in love who is yeah
and then I mean I really enjoy it here
both just being here and playing and
yesterday I ate it was I was witnessing
something special yet Lawrence you've
really done something special to make
all these grandmasters smiling it's
almost like the tournament didn't happen
they just liked that event Maxime
bascillica from France you had a pretty
decent tournament nice result
continuing result from Norway what are
your thoughts on this tournament I had a
great time I really enjoy myself just
like last year I mean I was also more
familiar with this city so that was good
and of course when the tournament was
over you know the part for my chess is
that the pleasure of not being the only
one getting some but beating I mean no
one's was there to give me company you
thought about the tour so far as well
there's two legs that have passed what
are your thoughts as this thing is now
going into the London chest classic I
mean I also
something to prove here compared to zero
so guys were playing I mean I was I mean
worst weighted you're here so of course
I had things to prove I prove some
things and I hope you know he will keep
on in London but it will not be easy as
well a nice giri from holland the
youngest player in the competition the
youngest boy in the Grantchester and
he's won the title is the most dapper
player thank thanks of course to his
lovely wife so picot a niche you had a
great event in London pretty solid
result here your thoughts about the
tournament as a whole and the grand
chest or so well it's already difficult
after so many people have said oh all
have nice adjectives about the
tournament and the place vocabulary is
not enough to introduce something new
but of course it's it's a well it's been
great to visit this place
I have little complaints the the area is
great you know a lot of different food
to eat although really a lot of Mexican
food as well I mean at some point I was
trying to find not a Mexican restaurant
and it were you Donald wrong it's
delicious
yeah no no but the weather was quite
difficult because there is this seducing
Park right nearby a huge one and he
walked there for too long under heat
it's quite tough but I think even the
best organizers are yet to find ways to
deal with the weather otherwise of
course it's been a great experience and
my tournament was was interesting I won
the first game and then I made so many
draws I already forgot how I managed to
win that game actually so but otherwise
yeah it's well can I complain too much
maybe thank you let's move to our third
place finisher on tibe race was it was a
tie for a second place the u.s.
number-one player Hikaru Nakamura
Nakamura this is your home I mean you're
the home boy here home favorite you
played and up and down sort of
tournament but you came back at the end
and won a big game what are your
thoughts about once again being able to
represent the United States here in st.
Louis well you know I think for me it's
it's really amazing to see how far
American Trust has come because growing
up when I was just a lowly master you
know trying trying to make my way in the
trust world my parents helped me out and
they sent me off to a lot of tournaments
in Europe and and so growing up I had to
play in Europe all the time and so
certainly being able to come back and
play tournaments in the US it all
started in 2009 of course with the US
Championship the first year that the st.
Louis hosted it and just to see how far
everything has come here it's amazing
and the fact that that I can represent
America here on home soil it's it's
always very special because I've spent I
spent so many years so many years
playing abroad and doing everything
having a chance to play here at home
there's nothing like it so I I find it
to be a really special experience even
though I tend not to play my best shots
in st. Louis but nevertheless sighs it's
always a pleasure being here and
representing America well said we'll
move on to the world champion Magnus
Carlsen who a nice giri complained that
you have a clothing sponsor so you have
to wear that jacket the other response
to initial right
I just want to that's all you you
definitely did not perform to your
standards at this event and it was a
really roller coaster for you after
Norway and and now this event what are
your thoughts now that it's concluded
and what do you need to do different as
you move forward I'm very happy to take
second place in this tournament with +1
and to be ahead of punished in the
standings despite having spiritualist
point that takes I think something I'm
very I'm very happy about everything
Anish you have a response to that I
never said so near to Magnus on the
press conference so I'm going to respond
to that now Magnus is the the leading
player in the world the Grantchester is
a big vision what do you see
significance and the importance of this
tour as we move forward into London and
2 years to come I think the tour has
great potential well I think we haven't
seen the best of it yet I mean to be
honest there have has been some growing
pains but I think all of these three
tournaments in themselves are great and
there will be more ones to be added so I
think it has great potential finally we
heard about some blitz last night
apparently you beat Lawrence Trenton
rook in a bunch of games what's up with
that that has been spoken about enough
already I'm not one who likes to to brag
about my own conquests that I mean that
that's a lie but I heard that you might
want to take me on tonight is that what
I know I actually have a different
proposal that's not going to happen Rhys
I decide that was about that but I think
tonight be sure should reverse the game
so that Lawrence is the one who has who
has a rootless but now his opponent will
be another Carlsen it will be my father
instead Lawrence I know you know
Lawrence immediately tweeted his loss to
you which is pretty impressive that he
was willing to do that he likes the
attention
even bad PR is good I don't think even
considers it bad PR thank you let's get
back to the real chess tournament the
winner of the grand chess to her second
leg the Sinquefield Cup Levon Aronian
having decided that he no longer needs
lucky facial hair now that the
tournament is over looking quite clean
quite handsome your feelings about
winning the sync they'll come first of
all actually in connection with what you
said I actually because my opponents are
so tough I didn't really have time to
have a shave and I so I'm sorry I mean
I'm sorry to my opponents that they had
to look at me and get scared you know
but generally I love being here you know
I I really like going into different
cities around the United States and
seeing the architecture and it comes to
San Luis I think there are not many
places where you can see such beautiful
buildings preserved and just next to
beautiful park so this for me is feels
like part of part of home yeah
definitely you know in America it's like
home another thing I want to mention is
the hospitality of everybody at the club
and you know somehow I think it's kind
of a virus people are so nice and so
lovely that even though American players
was they were really Hospital to me and
I I could feel their love and to
conclude my little speech I want to say
that as I already mentioned to Rex and
Ginny in history of chess they were I I
don't know anybody who sponsored chess
with so much love and with the feeling
that they don't really want anything
back from chess so I want to thank Ginny
and Rex Sinquefield for their support
and I want to say that for me every time
I come here and I see them I'm very
happy I know that our game is respected
and loved and will flourish as long as
you know their their work is teeing
thank you beautifully say
how that others get a chance to ask I'm
gonna do what I did last year and seek a
very quick response from all the players
I'm curious if you could purchase
anything a car whatever or across an
item off your bucket list but using only
your winnings from this tournament what
would you pick what would you buy or
what would you do we'll go from the left
like see me could you take the
microphone please generally January is a
busy time of the year for chess so it's
a problem every time but I really want
to go to Australia
I mean visit it watch the he is
Australian Open at the same time and you
know enjoy life but I never have see
occasion I think with my earnings in
this tournament
probably vacation I was thinking uh you
know I think I'd buy a coat because I
think I I think I could probably afford
it with the money all right
and to be honest this coat I think would
see tactics better than me okay I mean I
don't have anything special to say so
probably I would just go on a vacation
like like fishing so nothing nothing
maybe maybe I went like millionaire that
all have a better response with my
earning from here I would I think I
would buy it maybe piece of art and
there are experts as Rex engineer they
can recommend me you know I don't think
you can afford the art in their home
maybe a tiny piece I need well it's for
me it's a real question because I'm
coming back to an almost an empty house
which has to be taken care of so unlike
other people I already have to think
about it
so I will think about it probably buy a
new bike for Peter he needs a faster one
to keep up Peter hi Nancy yes you're one
of his second yes and in terms of
vacation I think we already spent I mean
I already spent the amount of time here
in st. Louis we've been around the zoo
which is really fantastic and it's free
for now so really love it
I may be Maurice I'll answer your
question once I win like this yeah you
know in in a very famous soviet
animation movie plus the questioner they
said in order to spend something you
first need to earn something and in
order to earn something you need to
perform better than i did well in my
case it's a question I should ask to my
wife
lady on the airport the world cup in
Baku five five days anyone else
re why I think you ever stood in the
back no
well that concludes my side of the press
conference and we'll hand it back to
Tony we have the space aliens coming and
it sounds like so now the moment we've
all been waiting for and that is to
recognize our top three finishers in the
2015 Sinquefield cup in third place the
chess player who inspires me to play
tactically and aggressively and go for
the win in every game Grandmaster st.
Louis's own Picaro Nakamura Garth you
could stand and as I as I call out your
name if you don't mind kind of moving to
the front here mayor slay me and Rex
will pose for a picture and Man Kings
Indian defense how come you can play it
like that
in second place the chess player who has
taught me that I will never fully
understand the game of chess no matter
how hard I try but it's still beautiful
to watch our world champion Magnus
Carlsen
and finally the 2015 seen field cup
champion
the Grandmaster has taught me what it
means to have the ability to play chess
brilliantly and at the same time be
humble demonstrating amazing
sportsmanship and be a true ambassador
for the game grandmaster Levon Aronian
and the bots if you have any other
remarks Ted
I thought I said my speech but I I am
granted possibility to thank everybody
again you know Chess Club is not just a
building without a doubt the people who
are there every day I mean even the most
primitive work you you cannot have a
chess club without people really loving
everybody who enters that house because
our game is in some way I think is a
spiritual game as two people get in a
contract and it in the contact and in
it's a it's some kind of a dialogue
without words so in order to have a good
chess game you need to have the spirit
of friendliness in my opinion so and
everybody all the volunteers and
everybody who works at the club Randy
with your wonderful work and the coming
commentators that are here you guys did
an amazing job making this tournament
especially this and of course I would
like to thank Rex and Jeanne for their
support and I hope this tournament will
go down in history as one of our own
Ian's with winds that will follow year
after year just kidding
thank you
once again thank you all for joining us
here at the 2015 Singh field cup make
sure to stay tuned to grande chest or
comm brawl up the upcoming information
about the 2016 grand chest tour and
we'll see you in London in December Oh
we'll see you tomorrow at ultimate moves
where I have to say I have to say hello
this is gonna be one heck of a
competition I wonder who's going to win
heckling in the trash-talking back and
forth
yeah check it out tomorrow grand
chessboard calm take care